Father in heaven even struck at us that
we should kneel before you as the king
of the universe and bow our heads
Lord we don't know when to come out or
go in we don't know her left hand her
right hand but you promised he'd be with
us if we called upon the name of your
sin they come to you in his name pudding
for your presence we asked for your Holy
Angels to try to put down these idols to
guard us to protect us to guide us give
us our spirit give us your wonderful
Easter show was Jesus we ask this in his
name your qualifying statement my
great-grandfather was a pastor in this
conference his brother my grandfather's
a literature evangelist his other
brother of the literature evangelist
also he went on to be a pastor and
missionary to India and served in Oregon
how many remember the old slave off
story Roy slave escape from death that
was my great uncle Harold Stryver and he
also trained Walter bland Victoria
became Union president in this Union
conference here in the Pacific Union my
wife is a Guthrie how of you how many of
you been to the ASI conventions paddlin
Guthrie is my wife's cousin in law the
Guthrie clan I've got five medical
doctors in my family and the reason I
mention this is not for any other
purpose in clarifying that we'll be
mentioning the medical field be
mentioning things in ministry so beware
the fact that my family have been in the
church for a long time seven generations
and we are loyal seventh animus
Christians who are coming before you
these next couple of days okay bear that
in mind thank you by the way my father
my wife's great-grandfather was
president of a Michigan conference and
the president of the Lake Union okay
so loyalty to his church silence in the
face of evil is evil itself God will not
hold us guiltless not to speak is to
speak not to act is to act German
Lutheran pastor Dietrich Bonhoeffer you
know what happened to him
they hung him right before the end of
the war he stood for the truth
inspiration says if God abhors one sin
above another of witches people are
guilty it is doing nothing in case of an
emergency indifference and neutrality in
a religious crisis is regarded of God as
a grievous crime and equal to the very
worst type of hostility against God it's
done in Volume three of the testimonies
page 280 paragraph 3 it was a beautiful
day and the pastor was writing the
underground to a location to meet up
with another pastor as they were getting
to go up to a camp camp Berkshire and
they were gonna camp meeting some we're
gonna have camp pitch and he's they came
out of the underground he noticed
everybody on their cell phones
looking up pointing on their cell phones
shouting and screaming and also in
stunned silence let's go ahead and run
that tape please the first tape that was
especially I'll once
turn it down turn the sound down thank
you watch it watch it
now 911 they were on a gas leak call
that's the first unit on a gas leak call
at that intersection with their wands to
detect gas and this is what they saw
going overhead two French brothers that
now dead brothers were filming a
documentary on a rookie firefighter of
New York City this eldest film was shot
go ahead turn it up my life as a fire
this was going to be something unusual
something tough but it would be
something we could handle
chief Pfeiffer made the first official
report
we'd have a number of floors on fire it
looked like the plane was beaming
towards the building transmit a third
along we'll have the staging area
probably a two-minute ride but it seemed
like it was forever because there was a
lot of things going through your head
felt sorry for the people the people who
started the building what was gonna
happen nobody had any idea we've never
experienced something like this before
everyone we just passed and it's looking
up it's like the world just stopped
we are just currently getting away at
the World Trade Center we have something
that has happened here flame and smoke
from one of the towers has occurred has
just occurred within minutes and as we
swung around in front of work world
trade my mind tells me wow this is this
is bad
what do we do what do we do for this
we park right under the awnings of white
a World Trade Center
but g54 he puts his Carol and I remember
asking you know chief can I come in with
you I won't
I won't become any of you and this is
yep
coming with me and never leave myself
they're going and I hear screams and
right to my right there is two people on
fire burning I just didn't want to film
that it was like no one no one should
see this Pfeiffer was the first chief
into the building right away a guy from
the Port Authority told him the damage
is somewhere above the 78th floor but
all you had to do was look around
it was obvious something had happened
right there in the lobby
you just you just saw that all the
windows blown out the lobby looked like
the plane hit the lobby as the president
of the United States then sitting
president george w bush said in an
elementary school classroom the White
House chief of staff at that time Andrew
card carefully chose these words on
September 11 2001 and this is what he
told the president he leaned over to the
president and said a second plane hit
the second tower America is under attack
fellow lawyers I would submit to you
today that God's remnant Church is under
attack the emerging Church didn't just
pop up over the last ten twenty or
thirty forty eight forty fifty years in
the Evans Church it has been emerging
since well for a long time now at least
a hundred years I didn't become aware of
this till about four years ago when the
puzzle came together I'm going to show
you what I feel is an understanding that
puzzle Satan will work as miracles to
deceive he will set up as power as
supreme the church may appear as about
to fall but it does not it remains well
the sinners in Zion will be sifted out
the chaff separated from the precious
wheat this is a terrible ordeal but
nevertheless it must take place none but
those have been overcoming by the blood
of the Lamb and the word of their
testimony will be found with a loyal and
true without spot or stain of sin
without guile in their mouths we must be
divested our self-righteousness
and arrayed in the righteousness of
Christ select a message it's volume 2
page 380 take out your Bibles please
please turn to first [__] verse 1
chapter 25 open book quiz first samuel
25 verse 1 whoever's got to first raise
their hand I'm gonna ask you a question
get it raised hand quickly 25 one
question is what prophet died in 1st
Samuel 25 verse 1 sameö turned over to
first say about 28 verses 1 to 25 first
samuel 28 verses 1 to 2 verses 1 to 25
king saul was about to go into battle
against to the philistines he did he
counseled but who was dead samuel where
did he go the Witch of Endor we get a
little gift for you this evening and
probably tomorrow we brought about a
thousand postcards of a little place and
we're going to kind of ask you some
courses about that place a little bit
later when a prophet dies according what
we just read does it get fuzzier or
clearer for God's professed people he
gets a whole lot fuzzier Barwon
questions for you my brother pastor
Byron Hill Calistoga I think in village
church my pastor be on the panel
tomorrow who died on July 15 at a place
called Elms Haven and white cottage
Ellen G white Byron stopped by there I
think was that Thursday I think it's not
buying just have some goodies for the
folks here now after Ellen White's death
there was a lot of developments both
good and bad one of the first issues was
the decision to build the eg white
Memorial Hospital in downtown Los
Angeles
this Twitter medical work into orbit
around the plants and policies of who
the American Medical Association that
wasn't all bad but it was certainly
wasn't the Lord's primary plan for
medical evangelism now I'd like to give
you one example of medical missionary
work properly conducted I've got a good
friend like to plug him if you don't
mind his name is pastor david guerrero
of the wisconsin conference david
guerrero runs a wonderful program
he's training the laity how to do the
work in the cooperation of the pastor
and the medical missionary work and the
local physicians and like to give you
write this down please get out your
pizza piece this is very important those
in the listening audience i'd like to
have you perhaps even contact him and
conference leaders out there bring him
in to train your pastors he'll come in
James and it'll get your congregation on
fire it's what you need we all need to
interesting they enough he's the pastor
and his wife runs the ministry your name
is Jacqueline it's called rekindle the
flame ministries rekindle the flame and
they're w-w-w rekindle the flame
ministries dot org they conduct
evangelism by teaching and preaching the
three hundred angels message in power
and training our people in medical
missionary work thank you much for that
now the lord's primary plan for the
medical missionary work wasn't
necessarily you know follow through is
it fully was and this connection VMA
created the perceived need to further
tyre educational system to the values
and methods of worldly education when
the issue of academic accreditation came
into the 1930s the lord told us that we
should be not the tale about the the
head
will you go to accreditation to outside
bodies we're getting their sample proved
upon our work they should be coming to
us for our approval for their work
now this went into the 1930s largely
because the influence of Ln LR can't con
ready the church in Europe was badly
shaken during that during it after World
War one perhaps the most fascinating of
the excuse me press the most lasting
result of this has been the SDA reform
movement 1927 AG Daniel's reintroduced
the issue of 1888 with his book Christ
Dustin remember the name of that book
Christ our what Christ our righteousness
Dustin Butler's here dust will be on our
panel he's the great-great-grandson of
the General Conference president GI
Butler now in the early 30s the
perceived need for more uniformity in
our structure and operations led to the
preparation of our first what church
manual the content of the book was
mostly all Bible and spirit of prophecy
but it increased the tendency for church
workers myself my family James all of us
that are in the ministry to look to
prepared interpretations and
applications of the divine council
instead of going to the council itself
about the same time we moved away from
the itinerant minister model to one
employing permanently settled pastors
firemen you know how that went until it
changed
Byron Hill pass for Calistoga I'm just
speaking to this largely ended the
establishment of new church
congregations growth did come to in a
sense of halt the way it had been
growing dramatically before on a more
positive note the 20s and 30s saw a
great deal of evangelism and the
expansion of foreign missions including
my great uncle new ideas such as radio
evangelism also came into use
with what success on the evangelistic
front though came the danger exalting
the what the worker himself instead of
the message now world war two occupied
much of the 1940s and resulted in quite
a number of unemployed European
Adventist academics when the
infrastructure of the church was
disrupted by fighting several these
professors came to the United States
after the war bringing a touch of
rationalistic infidelity with them
partially strengthened by their
influence the desire grew to
professionalize the Adventist ministry
this eventually led to making the
seminary a primary part of ministerial
education rather than the more
on-the-job apprenticeship approach which
we had used before with this development
came a greater emphasis on theoretical
theology and pressure to conform to
scholarly opinion in the 1950 General
Conference in San Francisco
unintentionally reignited interest in
1888 when General Conference leaders
interviewed Robert J Whelan and Donald K
short and asked them to prepare a
manuscript expressing their concerns
1880 reexamined was soon leaked before
beyond its originally intended circle
and has stirred the issues of
righteousness by faith and 1888 ever
since
too many minds the 50s 60s and 70s there
seemed a strong connection between the
concerns they had expressed and the
quick cascade of events involving the
rewriting
of the section on the human nature of
Christ in the book Bible rings to the
home in 1952 and the Martin barn house
conferences in 1955 question open book
quiz open book quiz what is the name of
the book put it in 1957
whoever can give me that answer first
that according to retired professor
George Knight easily qualifies as the
most divisive book in seventh-day
Adventist history anybody got an answer
for that one questions on doctrine oh I
would Mohnish you to go to ABC the
Grenda publications produced this
actually there's a book called a fork in
the road shows a ten-foot fork in the
middle of asphalt and is split in the
road by dr. Herbert Douglass how many of
you were at sacrament of Central when
dr. Douglass gave a symposium on this
issue I was there I think Allen Davis
was there it's available online I want
to say something I miss herb Douglass
the reason I'm standing here is because
herb Douglas the reason Rick Howard's
book is published as partially did a
herb Douglas he'll tell you about that
probably later on tonight or tomorrow
now these two major concerns the two
major concerns with questions on
doctrine were regarding what the final
atonement and a fallen sinful human
nature of Christ this laid the
foundation for what was to come
Robert Brinson beats sanctuary awakening
Fellowship of the 1960s and the heated
contention over the nature of righteous
by faith in the 1970s brims Meads role
as chief agitator of the church ended
when he did an about-face in the early
1970s when the mantle was tasked to
another man
you may have heard of who was born in
February 2nd 1929 in Townsville
Queensland Australia
what theological professor then with the
PUC from Australia
Desmond for that's right Dave Stewart
Desmond Ford on October 27 1979 Desmond
Ford delivered an address to the
Associates of Adventist forums now
adness forums held a Pacific Union
College entitled the investigative
judgment theological milestone or
historical necessity during which he
effectively and alienated himself from
mainstream
adventism when he announced that he
didn't believe the Church's teaching on
the sanctuary for 30 years there were
eight points that if you review Desmond
Ford's tape excuse me one moment if you
review - Desmond Ford's tape I have at
my vehicle I need to do it this time
because my CD is broken now but III
listen to Desmond Ford really when I
come to a location like this I listened
that thing and it gets me fired up and
then I listened to praise God - Ted
Wilson and he said nah girl sermon 2010
remember that you haven't heard it
listen to it you've heard it listen to
it again
he's the counterpoint to destined for in
that sermon praise the Lord for Ted
Wilson these are the challenge points
the nature of new light the
investigative judgment the day for your
principal the day for your prophetic
interpretation into the presence of God
within the veil 1844 Daniel 8:14 dan
Hebrews 9 tahadia now there's a common
denominator to all these developments
Ellen White once commented that the
exulting quote the exalting of the men
placed in positions of trust was quote
the bane of the church that's manuscript
releases 21 page 405 in each of the
events or issues listed above
every influence which has worked to
weaken God's church is linked to this
problem in many places Ellen White
called it placing man where God should
be whether the be the AMA the church
manual a gifted speaker or a theologian
the bright lights of academia or the
sage Scholastic of the theological world
every time we fail to look first and
foremost to the Word of God we quickly
find ourselves in deep trouble
or if we keep looking on these other
sources for wisdom we get ourselves into
deep trouble without ever even realizing
it after all the authority the issue
says we're doing the right thing so it
must be fine right they the 1980s and
1990s questioned what musical instrument
and we've been told would come into the
church just before the close of
probation the drums the things you have
described as taking place in Indiana the
Lord has shown me would take place just
before the close of probation every
uncouth thing would be demonstrated
there will be shouting with drums music
and dancing the senses of a trevor of
rational beings will become so confused
that they cannot be trusted to make
right decisions and this is called the
moving of the Holy Spirit the Holy
Spirit never reveals herself in such
methods in such a belem of noise this is
an invention of Satan to cover up his
ingenious methods from making not
effective pure sincere elevating and
nobly sanctifying truth for this time
better never have the worship of God
blended with music than to use musical
instruments to do the work which last
January was represented to me would be
brought into our camp meetings take heed
conference committees that organize
cavities
the true for this time needs nothing of
this kind of in the in its work of
converting Souls a bedlam of noise
shocks the senses and perverts that
which conducted a right might be a
blessing the powers of attached satanic
agencies blend with the den and noise to
have a carnival and this is termed the
Holy Spirit's working when the camp
meeting is ended the Good Witch ought to
have been done and which might have been
done by priests and chains of Sega truth
is not accomplished those participating
in the supposed revival receive
impressions which lead them adrift they
cannot tell what they formerly knew
regarding viable principles no
encouragement should be given to this
kind of worship the same kind of
influence came in after the passing of
time in 1844 the same kind of
representations were made men became
excited and were worked by a power
thought to be the power of God selected
messages pages 36 and 37 no positive an
example a good inspirational music is
hearing the Pacific Union College coral
or chorale sing acapella on the front
porch of Ellen White's house on a
Sabbath afternoon or even song the
program conducted the college on Sabbath
evening professor
Bruce Rasmussen is the choir director
music and voice teacher at the Civic
Union College
in the organist at the PUC Church you
know here's three Byron I think it's
three-year contract seven it pretty
quick here I think it is its three-year
contracts up and it would be a shame to
lose
Bruce Rasmussen PC how many of kids have
got to pee you see how many have been to
pee you see how many no Bruce Bruce
Bruce do you appreciate him praise the
Lord for Bruce Rasmussen dr. Knight you
have a diamond there and whose Rasmussen
we encourage you here too well I think
he's ready to sign up his contract
now and the hits keep on coming now
we've seen the death of Ellen White we
see the changes regarding how we
approach things we ended up with a with
leaning swords and directions
accreditation we've had how we conducted
our work that Domino fail questions on
doctrine came out and of course the Loni
mishchenko said this accounting two
years ago at Northern California that
that a a new theology came in of course
we're talking about what the new
theology of course desmond ford led the
charge but you know what brothers and
sisters he told our people that were in
favor of this to stay in the church and
to change the church from within
you know I agree with past president now
deceased president the General
Conference Robert Pearson he listed all
these things when he made his final
appeal to the church in 1973 after he
listed the things of disbelief you know
in the six-day creation many things you
know what he said he said don't let it
happen
I'm afraid that from my perspective and
I think the evidence that we did you
know Christ is a longing desire to come
back and we've delayed his coming as we
seek peace in the wrong places if one
does not understand the gospel in its
purity if one doesn't understand what it
needs to be justified by faith to be
born again become a new creature in
Christ if one has not submitted one's
will to the creator of the universe
well we're built with this void within
us we have to fill it and since we
perhaps some of us myself at once I've
described myself by the way as I walk
through these things by the way that's
where I was at point by point but the
Holy Spirit pulled me out as a brand for
the bow of the burning I was a four day
I was all the things to describe I saw
Jimi Hendrix twice ever heard of Jimi
Hendrix I know what it's coming from the
new theology hits the Domino drops we
walk into the celebration movement with
all of its trappings and because we look
for peace and all the wrong places were
wide open for something coming and the
emerging church I'm going to say again
has been developing for 100 years
the emerging church is much more than
the mysticism the spiritual formation
for heard about it is basically an
approach to scripture that is other than
taking scriptures that read and plain
thus saith the Lord it's taking a
Scholastic viewpoint and human
experience over a plane thus saith the
Lord you know what that's called
it's called higher criticism or the
historical critical method of
approaching the Bible or the new
hermeneutic you heard about the new
hermeneutic recently so I'd like to go
ahead and play a video I want to thank
publicly Aaron moose from Ohio Aaron put
a video together and we'll go and put
that out as we could the video is called
the shaking I'm John Bradshaw from it
has written many people are today very
concerned about this thing called
spiritual formation and I think with
good reason it's not an appropriate that
Christians today are asking some hard
questions and looking for answers that
frankly they deserve one of the issues
with spiritual formation is that if you
trace its roots back it goes back to the
spiritual disciplines of Ignatius Loyola
I think it's important that we don't
vilify people who may see things
differently from us but I also believe
it's important that we ask the questions
that need to be asked and certainly
those of whom the questions are being
asked have the responsibility to answer
some important questions and questions
such as why is this not based on what we
have historically taught as a church why
are these ideas coming to us from
theologians who are in essence
spiritualists when I hear that I think
to myself there must be a good answer to
that question somewhere but to be honest
with you I haven't heard anything
resembling a good answer to that
question yet why because there isn't one
and I believe there are several good
reasons why seventh-day Adventists are
very concerned we are a people of the
book and we're a people of Bible
prophecy and we know some of what's
coming down the line in the last days of
Earth's history you see some of us
believe we're this close to the return
of Jesus we're concerned
because we've been told in the Bible and
the spirit of prophecy that deceptions
are going to come startling deceptions
now let me ask you this question even if
you disagree with what I'm saying
especially if you disagree with what I'm
saying if a seventh-day Adventist
Christian knows that deception is coming
and then a seventh-day Adventist
Christian sees a movement flooding into
the church traces the roots of that
movement and say this leads to authors
that are Roman Catholic and the
orientation or perhaps they are a
spiritualistic in their orientation
these authors promote certain things
that we just don't believe now let me
ask you especially if you disagree with
me don't you think it's logical that
we'd be concerned if I'm concerned you
can see why I'm concerned because we're
this close to the end of the world and
this thing has a ring about it that
causes some questions to be asked
contemplative prayer and monastic
practices and spiritual disciplines that
go back in some directions that alarm
some of us the devil said 20-30 years
ago I'm going to introduce into
Christianity new age prayer and
meditation techniques I'm just going to
ask question not make a claim the
question I'm going to ask is could we be
seeing that in our own church right now
if the answer is no thank the Lord if
the answer is yes then what we need to
do is flee this and make it our covenant
with God to stand on the Bible and the
Bible alone as our rule of faith and
practice there can be no revival that
unless it is based solidly on the Bible
itself now we would say seventh-day
adventists that our revival could be
based on the Bible and supported very
strongly by the spirit of prophecy I'm
very thankful to Aaron and call it for
their work in encouraging all of us to
be involved in true revival and true
Reformation would you stand with them
would you make a covenant with God that
your spiritual journey or spiritual
growth will be based on the
supported by the wise counsel we receive
in the spirit of prophecy would you make
that your covenant we're so close to the
end of time
we know that deceptions will abound we
don't want to make accusations about
anything or towards anybody but we do
hope and pray that what is promoted as
bringing spiritual revival and
Reformation will be solid and will be
biblical and will be seventh-day
adventists I encourage you make your
covenant join me join Aaron join collet
join the many who wish to see Jesus come
soon he will come after a period of
great revival in his church and in the
end in the world and we know that that
revival is going to come when we commit
to Christ pray and study and build our
lives in our experience solidly on the
Bible as the Word of God the time of the
Golden Calf there was a shaking that
took place among God's people and it
always revolved around the ones who
wanted to stay true to the Word of God
and follow the worship of God the way he
had decide designed and others that were
looking for something else
they were compromising their worship
they're compromising the word of truth
with the pagan teachings and practices
of the nations around them that same
threat faced as God's people in the last
days where instead of looking vertically
to God we begin to look horizontally and
compare ourselves among ourselves with
the other religions and begin to
integrate and adopt some of the pagan
practices of even other Christian
churches it's the the Babylonian food
that Daniel said he would not eat some
of the people of God are now
compromising and you know we can just
see over and over in the word that when
this happened it did not end well jesus
said unless were converted and we become
as little children we can't enter the
kingdom of God the Lord wants us to just
love the Bible teach and preach the
Bible in its simplicity if we want to
know how to pray we don't need to find
some kind of spirit
allistic formula for that how did Jesus
pray how did Daniel pray how did Solomon
pray their prayers are here we should be
modeling our prayers after what we find
in the Word of God it's really not that
complicated friends but you'll find as
we enter the last days if we are
faithful to the Word of God and if we
are preaching and teaching and living
and praying the way that is taught in
the Word of God there's going to be a
conflict it may not be popular in the
world there's going to be shaking
there's going to be a struggle you know
we need revival and revival is going to
come when God's people really return to
the Lord with all their hearts and they
pray and they embrace the original
covenant that the Lord made that new
covenant the Jesus sealed with his own
blood and I'd like to appeal to you
friends to say I want to return to the
simplicity of a devotional life based on
the Word of God based on praying like
Jesus prayed based on sharing our faith
with the world and invites you to
participate in returning to this
covenant of God returning to God's
covenant and join this movement friends
that's my appeal for you and that's my
prayer hello everyone
my name is Howard pith and I'm delighted
to be or under lighted that you folks
are here with us because we have a very
important topic to discuss it's the
topic of contemplative prayer I was
asked last year to write this book and
we've called it the dangers of
contemplative prayer and so we need to
talk about this heresy one man has
called it heresy on steroids it's been
present in other elements of the church
the Catholic Church and so forth for a
long time but now it's coming into
Protestant churches and sad to say it's
even infiltrating to some extent our own
Adventist Church if God really intended
us to indulge and kind of played a
prayer get into the silence with the
mantra and mysticism why didn't he say
so why didn't he teach it in his word
now in conclusion I'd like to read a
quote from my book
now having examined the facts we can
conclude only that spiritual formation
with its mystical silence of
contemplative prayer in the emerging
church is a modern-day Trojan horse
quietly smuggled into its christianity
by the devil himself and we don't want
any part of it
I hope that you will make a commitment a
covenant to join with me and Aaron and
Colette and others who are concerned
about this menace to Christianity to
come out of spiritual formation if
you've been involved in it and deceived
by it God wants his people whole and
unified so we pray and we hope that you
will pray ask the Lord to help you in
this important move to go to his word he
wants you to listen to him
as he talks to you in the pages of
Scripture so let's go back to the Bible
and away from these things that draw us
away god bless you in your decision I'm
her Berglas listen to many men and women
already telling you how the spiritual
formation has come into the world but
you know how often how quickly came into
the Adventist Church I've been preaching
and people before me have been preaching
and writing books on the threefold union
of Protestants Catholics and
spiritualism we didn't know what that
really would turn out to be it seemed
too fantastical well let me tell you
friends we're living in it now the
emerging church is that fulfillment of
the threefold Union in closing I'd like
to have you open your Bibles please
okay let's go the C to the book of
Zechariah huh you know it's in the back
of the Old Testament towards the New
Testament okay right back there Malachi
and all those little books back there
Habakkuk and those things and it's
chapter one
chapter 1 verse 3 Zechariah chapter 1
verse 3 therefore therefore say now unto
them thus saith the Lord of hosts turn
ye unto me saith the Lord of hosts and I
will turn unto you saith the Lord of
hosts I'd like to make an appeal there
are organizations among us and
individuals and I'm not going to name
fully but I'm to have you consider what
we did at Sacramento thoroughly I would
have you consider reading Rick Howard's
book and make a rebellion meet it Dave
Fiedler's book tremble howard best book
the danger the contemplative prayer with
an open honest heart
Tim Sam Alex
Terry Jacob I appeal to you to return to
Him let's bow our heads
father help us turn to you
you